in the week the hundred and 19th
teenager died on London streets it's
become clear that public faith in the
police is a breaking point these brutal
murders in London and nationwide are
down to a dereliction of duty by our
police our politicians and our judges a
damning new report says police are
losing control of our streets ninety
percent of all crimes go unsolved and
75% of all call-outs offer non crimes so
instead of talking about police cuts
let's focus on the people who have been
failed by the police the people who have
died who live in fear abandoned by a
force they feel is more interested in
online crime than real crime the police
exist to protect us and to keep the
peace yet we have young man armed to the
teeth swagger your anger our city's
confident no one will stop them
meanwhile police time is consumed by
pasting agendas online crimes and
so-called hate crimes yes we have many
dedicated police officers but their
bosses have forgotten what the job is
about and what their priorities are they
need to stop bleating about cut and
remember people's lives matter more than
political correctness I've got a lot of
sympathy with what you say about the
police not getting distracted about hate
crime and so on but I think I'm gonna
take us you on the knife crime question
and forgive me I'm probably a little bit
engaged with this one because three of
the killings in London took place in
this year within ten minutes of my own
doorstep and one of the two hotspots in
London there two postcodes n22 wood
green and 17 Tottenham were where I grew
up and went to school and the road I
walk to school every day is one of the
worst places in in the capital for this
now what is it really interesting is
there's actually no evidence that police
numbers make the slightest bit of
difference to this and you know it's
common sense if you are going to do
going for stabbing if you're arranging
to have a fight with somebody which is
how this works you don't do in a place
where the police are gonna turn up so
police numbers make almost no impact on
this the police stop the stopping of the
stop and search which to reason I did
when she was Home Secretary she could
stop and search by 80% and it's no
coincidence in the years following that
Miriam has rocketed well I don't think
they're having partly been responsible
for persuading Tereza May to change stop
and search regulations a point about
stop and search was not about reduction
in numbers it was in reduction in
unfairness and disproportionality but
let me come to a point where perhaps you
wouldn't expect to hear this from me I
think that you're actually being overly
politically correct I think I think
you're making a big deal about police
numbers which have nothing to do with
what is actually going on the street
because one of the things you don't want
to say is if you look at every face with
two exceptions of those who have been
killed in London everyone who looks like
me yeah the one thing we will not talk
about is the fact that this crime or
this wave of crimes is racially coded
and let me make one other point about
this ten years ago when I was actually
responsible for some of this I wrote to
Gordon Brown who's been chanta asked me
to do some work on it for him and I
wrote to him and I said look you've got
to start by acknowledging who this is
happening to and where it's happen
before you start to think about how
we're going to do anything about it
because if you don't you're gonna spend
a lot of money on the wrong things and
in this particular case what will happen
is you will continue to have I feel this
black children dying because actually
you're too afraid to tackle the actual
problem I'll let you guys it I
completely agree with that but you know
I I think that we I think that the
government and police have been
politically correct in attacking this
form of fact which is why I think the
stop and search was reduced because we
know that the government and police were
accused of being racist and stopping
young black boys but I am sure the black
mothers of all those dead children would
actually rather their sons had been
stopped and searched that actually have
been stabbed and I
and I think political correctness is the
reason that young black boys are being
slain on our streets every day because
we want to be seen as this tolerant
diverse compassionate society but
actually we've got to exactly what
you're so we've got to look at where the
problems are and they're happening in
areas like Tottenham and I read
something that you wrote not to very
long ago where you said no you should be
having higher higher concentrations of
policemen in the areas like you just
described because police we don't say
them on the streets anymore and if
you're telling kids we're not gonna stop
and search you they're gonna carry
that's completely right but my point is
you're getting you're going down the
wrong road here because the reason some
of this is happening is it's not about
whether you got more police or not it is
who are these kids
ten years ago one of the things that
happened was that we had a flood of
children I agreed with this who came
from war zones these children had seen
things that no person no adult should
have to see but they saw these things
before they were ten years old
rape maiming all the rest of it we
brought them here we dumped them in
schools we gave them nothing no support
we gave them no help and then 10 years
later I wonder what's happening 17 and
18 year old right you're right that
Teresa Mays DNA is all over this problem
because this Home Secretary and I'm
dismayed to hear Trevor that you think
you were right to persuade the number of
stops to come down as long as they are
professionally and disproportionality I
didn't care about a number you've argued
almost against yourself because quite
rightly you point to that depressing
gallery of faces that stares out of us
every morning almost every morning and
with virtually no exception they're all
black or mixed-race faces so there's no
point that we have to stop mostly black
males if we're going because they're
mostly you keep thinking stop and search
is going to solve this problem is it's
part of it it's part it's part it's it
is there are many many ways that you
need to address that
you're also also right that there needs
to be more support but the police in
London and and it's worth saying this is
a national problem we're talking around
250 murders across the earth stabbings
across the whole of the counties are
huge huge figures you don't get to solve
it overnight
the police have lost part of the streets
in this city in London which is wholly
wrong as I say Teresa mayors over there
and I just sense I just sense that Anne
left we start getting tough unless we
crack down on this it is going to get a
lot worse and please don't give me
Gregor welcome please don't give me this
austerity line that is the biggest load
of cobblers I've ever heard no I'm just
saying I hear it because we can oh it's
because there's a start there's
austerity in Jay wicks and the poorest
parts of Plateau out by that they don't
stab there's austerity in Sunderland
there is something unique to London
culture did you're not going to get a
crack down in Guildford Surrey are you
what's the point of that let's just have
a look at what Sadiq as the Mayor of
London said there are deep societal
problems that leads to young people get
involved in crime and excuse me from
analyses but it means tackling the
causes of violent crime that means
looking at adverse childhood experiences
look at the families where there may be
children experiencing domestic abuse
children who may have mental health
challenges
I mean what's interesting with him he's
saying it's a sort of ten year there's a
you need a ten year program to do
something about it
binge is now Trevor you've been involved
do you think that's right do you think
you need a long term is only a long term
solution I think there is a long term
solution to to essentially stopping the
long term cause but I think you could do
something about it now
because it's time I also think this this
whole Glasgow thing is it's just
nonsense it's absolutely the research
the research on glass on the Glasgow
savings it's pretty clear that generally
speaking what was happening there were
random heat-of-the-moment stabbings and
you know we don't need to go into the
culture and the drinking and all that
but that's what the research says in
London this is planned it is strategic
the gangs
arranged to kill somebody because they
did something that you didn't like it's
a whole different problem so so what do
you do well I've been listening
patiently to all of you and especially
you to Carol and Rover and I mean Nick
said you're both right I think you're
both wrong so Carol I think you're wrong
because you're suggesting that cuts the
policing have no impact on crime so just
did not you said that cuts the policing
have nothing to do with this particular
issue comfortably we've lost 14,000
officers in ten years we still have 122
thousand officers who actually should be
able to stop gangs killing each other on
street corners it's not
the government has reduced central
government funding to the police by 25
percent since 2010 eleven there is no
question that has affected people's
safety and if you just broaden it out
beyond this knife crime black people are
disproportionately victims of crime
across the board poor areas people are
experiencing more crime
policing a thinker Trevor you're wrong
because this isn't the elephant in the
room we never talk about we always talk
about knife crime as a black problem
talk about black on black crime
we kind of Zadar crime it has been
mentioned the victims are black debate
with Carroll where it's been framed as
some kind of innate savagery around
young black men this is always framed as
a black thing there's even been anybody
has mentioned that this has been a black
on black no it was about something
different I know that you know we even
know the names of trying to and even
know the reason we even know that the
phrase black on black crime is because
it's something that has had currency in
framing you as a black issue any white
is real so it's true that the victims
and the perpetrators in this case are
mainly young black men from areas yes
and that's why and like Trevor I have a
personal investments cuz I know people
who've been involved and the thing that
I think my framing is wrong wrongly is
that we talk about this as if these
stabbings are somehow of course there
are symptom they are a symptom of
something much bigger that's happening
in society the reason I find this whole
debate frustrating is I feel like we
know the answers ready for example look
at what wealthy people do for their kids
they put them in excellent schools they
give them stimulating extracurricular
activities they live in good housing
they have access to high-quality food
cool kids stop we are dumping children
sort of standard housing poor education
through their ins
can't supervise them because they're
working in it's people making excuses
for these cubicles now excuses people
who work on this issue who actually know
more about it than I or you care because
they are working with the people involve
the perpetrators and the victims say
over and over again that the causes are
social exclusion poverty lack of
opportunity and things that we know how
to cure if we're injured but we're not
really interested so why are we having
the draught of reasons let's see what
the Home Secretary is saying about this
when you talk to police officers also
the work to be done around your powers
and that's why this great support for
example the offensive weapons bill which
will make it even harder for people to
get hold of knives and other offensive
weapons taking more these weapons of our
streets and the police will also rightly
say that this isn't just a job for them
there's a job for many other parts of
the public sector and that's why I'm so
keen on this públicas what I call the
public health approach a last word for
now I sense from Home Secretary Sajid
Javid speaking exclusively to Sky's
deputy political editor
better it be Trevor I'll just say
they're not stabbing each other in
Hastings or Sunderland AJ way or J week
where they're just as poor